[Musique]
aujourd'hui attentats m'ennuie une
semaine presque 500 kilomètres carrés de
forêt de terre sont partis en fumée en
colombie-britannique plus de 16000
personnes sont toujours évacués à l'est
du canada l'aquarelle un incubateur à
omar qui fait des heureux en gaspésie
mais d'abord les métiers de la
communication et les défis inhérents
être de la diversité quand on veut être
journaliste
[Musique]
bonjour ici les noms des marteaux
bonjour ou jeu qui nous suivent sur
facebook live d'aussi loin que je me
souvienne dans ma carrière on va
toujours se ruiner en disant il n'y a
pas de travail dans ce métier là
oublient ça avoir mes cheveux qui sont
passés dans ce métier après sa bosse au
soleil et d'aussi loin que je me
souvienne aussi majeur j'ai eu un malin
plaisir à faire mentir l'adage
non mais écoutez d'un métier qu'on
exerce compte qu'on pratique avec
beaucoup de délectation soit faut dire
par contre qui ici avec bien ma couleur
de peau
je suis mon accent mis mon nom également
ben oui en télévision et vision canada
estime que cette année en amérique
latine non pas encore mais oui les
blancs blancs en neige
comment que le bronzage partis allemands
font entrer effectivement chasse et
monochrome sas et blanc surtout en
fiction en information il ya un certain
changement est ce que c'est un
changement certains les défis inhérents
être de la diversité quand on veut faire
le métier de journalisme mes collègues
j'ai invités aujourd'hui vous la
connaissez à radio canada international
alice chantal john duncan gamme d'accès
donc assez kilométrique les opprimés
nord qui lui d'argentine vous êtes du
cameroun dirigé et vanessa dessiner
notre toute jeune chaîne pouces
oui c'est sacré elle deuxième génération
voilà six ans je suis né ici de marins
ici bon on va vous de partir avec nabawi
[Rires]
vouloir faire ce métier comment c'est
arrivé dans votre vie c'est
un parcours assez
qui a pris du temps en fait avant que je
me dirige vers le journalisme mais j'ai
suivi un parcours tout ce qui est plus
traditionnel c'est à dire que je suis
allée bon saut secondaire au cégep j'ai
eu beaucoup d'intérêt pendant cette
période là pour les ordres notamment
théâtre mais aussi je me suis toujours
sentie comme étant très engagé donc mon
père c'est quelqu'un qui vient d'haïti
qui a pas beaucoup d'éducation mais qui
une très grande culture politique et
c'est quelque chose qui m'a transmis est
très jeune donc m'intéresser aux grandes
questions sociales politiques
économiques
donc ça a un peu marqué mon parcours je
me suis dirigé au cégep en sciences
humaines internationales brousse où j'ai
fait de la science politique et de la
géographie de l'histoire et ça m'a donné
la piqûre pour continuer dans cette voie
là j'espérais devenir une grande
diplomate en fait c'était un peu je
crois à l'époque de michael je me disais
tu peux le temps j'ai le temps encore
une passante qui a frôlé radio canada
international qui était premier ministre
du canada
j'espère que mon parcours pour me servir
c'est alors je me suis dirigé en
sciences politiques à l'université avant
de me rendre compte que finalement ça ne
me convenait pas il manque et l'aspect
terre y manquait l'aspect auprès des
gens parce que quand on fait sciences
politiques à l'université on est
beaucoup beaucoup dans les premières
années dans la théorie classique donc la
pensée politique classique on analyse
beaucoup mais on s'approche peu des gens
vont on sort peu de l'université et
c'est quelque chose qui me manquait un
peu
donc j'ai réorienté mon parcours j'ai
commencé à faire des certificats à
l'université de montréal
c'était une super avenue parce que ça me
permettait de travailler deux jours et
d'aller à l'école soir et voilà dire vie
des étudiants 2017 et j'ai découvert le
scientifique en coopération
internationale donc qui était vraiment
axé sur l'humanitaire le maintien de la
paix le développement et ça nous
permettait de réaliser un stage sur le
terrain donc encore une fois d'aller à
la rencontre des gens et de mesurer
l'implication à l'international mais
aussi ici chez nous plus près nos
communautés puissent et c'est avec un
peu cette perspective là que je me suis
engagé en communication appliquées puis
ensuite en relations publiques en
pensant que je travaillerai pour des ong
en faisant de la communication et bien
non je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait
en plus prenez valeur c'est-à-dire le
journal
oui alice vous avez cameroun d'origine
il ya en france une maîtrise sur la
difficulté effectivement ça fait mais en
fait je viens du cameroun
j'ai travaillé à la télévision nationale
du cameroun notamment et puis je suis
passé par la france aussi où j'ai fait
quelques études en journalisme reporter
d'image c'est à dire être capable de
produits en toute autonomie
c'est à dire pouvoir faire de l'image de
la caméra du son et du montage comme les
moussons voilà donc et peu après je
poserai valises en amérique du nord et
il faut dire avant d'entrer dans le vif
du sujet que cette amitié qui m'a
toujours passionné
disons je viens d'un pays en
développement le cameroun où nous sommes
inondés par toute sorte d'image qui
vient d'ailleurs la télévision française
ben oui c'est ça la télévision française
avec des journalistes talentueuses comme
christine ockrent
anne sinclair est parmi les hommes ppda
patrick poivre d'arvor que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup admiré quand j'étais au
cameroun
et donc je me dis mais pourquoi pas je
vais je vais tenter ma chance je vais me
lancer dans ce métier là et j'entre à
l'école de journalisme de yaoundé après
trois ans j'obtiens mon diplôme mais on
ne sait jamais les niveaux il n'y a pas
de métier ne seriez pas de travail dans
ce qu'il fait là où il disait la
télévision nationale du cameroun est
tout jeune en 1985 lorsque la télé fait
son entrée au cameroun vraiment c'est la
fascination pour tout le monde il ya de
la place pour tout le monde parce que
c'est tout nouveau c'est tout le terrain
reste vierge
et donc il fallait occuper un moment
donné et nous nous trouvons donc à la
télé donc disons c'est un métier que
j'ai beaucoup aimée dont une fois au
canada une fois ici je me dis bon ok je
suis dans un nouvel environnement je
suis dans un nouveau pays comme l'avait
si bien dit boucar diouf lui son
histoire c'est mon grand père me disait
mon grand père disait tout le temps
écoutez quand vous arrivez quelque pas
prenez le temps de connaître le pays de
connaître les acteurs de connaître
l'histoire du pays pour pouvoir en
parler je me dis ben voilà j'arrive dans
un pays que je connais pas il faut que
je retourne à l'université que
j'apprenne à connaître
pays que j'apprenne son histoire d'où
l'intérêt d'aller faire une maîtrise en
communication publique à l'université
laval pour apprendre à connaître le
canada à connaître ces acteurs pour être
capable d'en parler aisément c'est ce
que je fais et 813 vous avez remarqué
que comme le disent en ouverture c'est
très monochrome et c'est pas évident là
dessus non non c'est pas évident du tout
et on poursuivra on parlait de l'est
aussi léo lui de l'extrême ouest de
l'argentine oui presque dans les
contreforts des da cordillère des andes
et san luis
ce pays-là ce beau pays les hivers sont
des hivers doux et les été à les étés de
janville c'était chaud vous avez fait
vous êtes ceux d'un journalisme vous
avez enseigné aussi il m'a mis un
transfert dit je veux changer de lit je
vais pour les enfants qui jouent déjà ça
en fait qu'un nom est arrivé au canada
j'ai toujours mon père y était en soi
réalisateur l'argentine je les ai pas
vus travailler en fait quand j'étais
plus jeune je suis les plus jeunes des
six alors j'ai pas eu la chance de les
voir travailler mais à travailler la
télé a travaillé à la radio aussi en
argentine à mendoza particulièment alors
j'ai toujours les petites heures je
savais que j'aimais ça on entendait
ensemble avec mon père à dieu qu'on a
internationale en français en anglais en
espagnol en ondes courtes leçons et
l'ont longtemps qui est
je poursuis mon frère qui est ménagé au
canada ça fait plus est n'a pas pu
reprendre alors on est venu après avec
ma femme qui est mon histoire avec les
journalistes mais c'était toujours comme
ça je l'aimais ccc si c'est ça que
j'aime était en ondes les micros la
technique la façon en fait là pouvoir
communiquer mettre en commun les choses
c'est quelque chose qui était toujours
là mais quand on arrive au canada puis
on parle pas la langue
y'en a toujours c'est peut-être cette
drôle d'accent c'est difficile travail
et en prime ça fait c'est difficile pour
les gens qui viennent de la fait que
c'est difficile pour les gens qui
viennent même de la france et la
belgique parce que l'accent c'est
quelque chose c'est un accent totalement
différent donc il ya cette barrière
linguistique qui représente un véritable
défi niant pour les immigrants on a beau
être francophone on aboie appris le
français n'est ce pas comme langue de
scolarisation
c'est pas toujours évident de se faire
comprendre dans un contexte où l'accent
est totalement différent par exemple
quand je venais d'arriver je l'entendais
dire à chaque reprise
est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire à
nouveau parce que j'ai pas compris
donc je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour surmonter cette barrière là je
parle un français international en
france je me fais comprendre facilement
le cameroun est un pays qui a été
colonisé par la france
donc nous avons pratiquement la même
façon de prononcer des mots de dire des
choses en amérique du nord au québec
notamment c'est pas c'est pas la même
chose c'est pas la même façon de parler
c'est pas la même utilisation des
concepts certains mots ici qui ne
signifie pas exactement la même chose
qu'en france
lorsque par exemple j'ai dit franchement
j'étais vous avez un monde comme vous
dire j'étais séduit quelque chose comme
ça c'était écoeurant
chaussée selon l'intonation que ça veut
dire tout autre chose
pensons à la mecque du nord au québec où
qu'on soit en france ou même au cameroun
ne veut pas forcément dire et il y en a
tout plein comme ça aussi le dôme de la
suisse a ici j'aimerais juste aller avec
vous d'instinct à grandir dans une
société
ici vous êtes bel et bien d'ici à mars
ans le 4 mars
sauf que à l'intérieur de la maison mais
tahitien donc et cette dichotomie l'un
est la couleur de la peau est-ce que ça
touche
est ce que c'est vous avez presque dans
un bon teint le vous oui qu'en juin on
le disait hier à quelqu'un en fait
quelqu'un me disait plutôt que diversité
est un besoin de super intéressant au
niveau de l'employeur c'est dans l'air
du temps on se pose ces questions là
donc oui les regards se tournent un peu
pour voir ces nouvelles voies qui
apporte une perspective différente sur
la société québécoise
donc c'est une bonne période pour être
journaliste par contre c'est quand ça
reste très difficile de faire sa place
mais bon on est encore si peu nombreux
et parfois on se heurte à des
sensibilités parce que c'est très dur en
fait d'amener ses collègues les
employeurs à remettre en question des
comportements qui leur ont été
inculquées pendant très très longtemps
donc de se faire confronter
récemment j'ai eu une conversation avec
une collègue sur le racisme une collègue
blanche dans le milieu des
communications justement parce que bon c
est après un vox pop et j'avais signalé
qu'il y avait peu de personnes de la
diversité dans ce vox pop
donc c'est un vox pop qui se déroulait
dans une université montréalaise au
centre-ville de montréal
il n'y avait pas un seul intervenants
issus des communautés culturelles et je
lui ai fait remarquer et à la fin d'un
échange assez musclé elle me dit mais
mon dieu c'est dont 20 confrontant cette
conversation là et oui c'est ça c'est ça
en fait la conversation avec la
diversité font la diversité une
conversation qui va confronter
donc oui c'est une bonne période parce
qu'il ya une sensibilité
les gens sont prêts à avoir cette
discussion cette discussion là mais ça
se fait quand même assez ça se fait
assez difficilement mais c'est très
éprouvant des deux côtés je crois
ajouter quelque chose mais en fait non
j'ai fait un changement de carre en fait
je ne travaille pas comme journaliste je
suis plutôt en charge des questions
difficiles à la fois sur deux cette
polyvalence
j'ai changé mais j'ai conduit un contact
et j'aime ça est toujours pouvoir être
ici puis partager les coûts c'est pour
moi quelque chose de spécial et ce
qu'est ce que tu me dis juste que c'est
un créneau pour vous personnellement ou
est-ce que deux diplômes non je suis un
journaliste je suis un communicateur
j'ai un accent soit j'ai je sais écrire
en français ses grands anglais jack en
espagnol également japon c'est ça que je
veux faire ou c'était dans sa façon ses
imprimés vivere il faut trouver quelque
chose
non en fait et on a des cas on a des cas
des gens qui est qui a pu vraiment
traversé cette ligne
cette ligne spéciale de lax empiète
retrouver un place puisse se développer
son travail puis fabien en fait martine
mobilières et auprès de notre collègue
qui y venaient y vient de la colombie
son accent il va être toujours là lui on
ne maîtrise plus blanches celui-ci on a
fait un effort pour s'adapter qu'on a
fait l'effort de s'adapter à la culture
et de s'intéresser à la société
d'acquêts différence parce qu'il n'est
pas question non plus d'assimiler
désigné en mai comme moi j'ai connu déjà
en argentine que ben en fait des départs
des amis qui sont arrivés
la vague d'émigration en 1930 en
argentine mais toujours son acteur en
son accent français
de fait on se mettrait en italie c'était
toujours là c'était bien de l'avoir mais
par contre ici parfois on trouve déjà
qu'ils sont pas habitués au kiki qui ont
pas la même
la même approche avec les accents on
comprend que c'est lié à l'histoire
évidemment la protection de la langue
justement cette sensibilité de cette
sensibilité-là devrait nous permettre de
comprendre que les gens aussi sont fiers
doudou petit il faut les mariés en fait
en fait moi j'ai qu'un j'ai fait toutes
les démarches pour venir au canada je
parle l'anglais et quand je suis arrivé
au québec je fais le corps français
depuis je pense un petit peu d'anglais
maintenant ma vie c'est en français puis
en espagnol mais c'est quand on embrasse
un land
mais les gens qui de l'autre côté y est
pas tout à fait c'est pour cette raison
que moi j'ai toujours eu un problème
avec un concept celui du
multiculturalisme je suis plutôt
favorable à l'interculturalisme alain
qu'est ce que cela veut dire un
développement
mélangez intégrer des cultures dit non
un développement séparé où on a dédaigné
biteau on forme des ghettos avec des
gens dans des quartiers des des
personnalités différentes des groupes
différents qui forment le groupe a pas
et qui s'est récemment des clichés rares
au québec au canada
on est sur deux c'est là tout le
problème c'est drôle ça c'est dans mes
cours de coopération internationale
beaucoup de ces mensurations du rallye t
je m'adresse aux femmes ce métier si oui
ça me dire coin 2017 les défis avec un
un axe 1 2 une couleur de peau
détroit est d'être une femme est bien
j'imagine que cette avant première sont
énormes
déjà quand on est femme dans un métier
majoritairement occupés par les hommes
franchement il faut se lever tôt le
matin faire ses devoirs faire c'est de
voir ça veut dire quoi être à la hauteur
ça veut dire aller chercher les outils
dont on a besoin pour s'imposer comme il
se doit dans ce métier là ça veut dire
vraiment mettre tous les atouts de son
côté faire tomber la barrière
linguistique
ça c'est très important la langue pour
nous est un outil de travail et
s'exprimer sans faire de faute
être capable de communiquer communiquer
ça veut dire quoi susciter l'intérêt de
l'autre fait en sorte qu'il y ait un
feedback être une femme noire venue
d'afrique comme moi c'est un triple défi
c'est un triple défi parce qu'on ne
regarde comme des personnes qui viennent
de pays sous développés qui sont
forcément mal informé et mal cultivé qui
ne savent pas grand chose c'est être
capable de démontrer le contraire
à travers ce que nous faisons à travers
notre travail à travers notre
connaissance des dossiers que nous
traitons au quotidien c'est être capable
de parler sur un pied d'égalité avec les
autres
être capable de leur dire écoutez je
suis différente et je les assume
ne pas avoir honte de sa couleur comme
certaines personnes ont tendance à le
faire
pouvoir s'affirmer et pouvoir vraiment
s'imposer dans ce métier là qui est
large mais une fois de plus dominé par
les hommes et nous sommes dans le
contexte nord américain dans la mettrais
dans mon essai de maîtrise je cite un
enseignant un éminent enseignants de
l'université laval qui s'appelle florian
sauvageau
ce sont des joueurs sur une 6e sauvageau
qui nous dit écoutez dans les rédactions
ici en amérique du nord
les blancs veulent travailler avec des
personnes qui leur ressemble résultat
des courses nous avons 97% des
journalistes dans toutes les rédactions
qu'on soit leur a dit
la télévision à la presse écrite qui
sont des blancs alors quand on est noir
femmes venus d'afrique ou d'haïti
mais la route est longue mais
franchement il faut pas se décourager il
faut s'imposer mais ça je dois dire
quand même que j'ai souvent le bénéfice
du doute d'abord parce que je suis né
ici alors j'ai pas la question de
l'accès n'est ce pas est aussi j'ai la
pâleur de la peau donc le colorisme
évidemment ça laisse toujours planer un
doute quant à mes origines parfois on va
penser justement c'est ça exactement
donc ni les très très prononcé j'ai
envie de vous parler un peu de la
théorie de l'intersexualité je le dis
souvent le le poing levé moi je suis une
féministe endurcis il utilise une
théorie qui a été développé dans les
années 90 par une chercheure kimberley
crunch a un qui dit que certains groupes
d'individus sont confrontés à plusieurs
problèmes donc qui ralentissent leur
avancement dans la société par rapport à
d'autres par exemple le fait d'être une
femme noire donc c'est la double
discrimination le fait d'avoir le sexe
de femme et le genre féminin pardon et
le fait d'avoir la peau noire
ça fait en sorte qu'on se retrouve
confronté dans le face aux boys club
d'une part et de l'autre quand on va
chercher de l'appui auprès des femmes
blanches par exemple on se retrouve
parfois confrontés au racisme
donc c c c c c sur deux tableaux en fait
que la discrimination se joue et comme
le dit alice c'est très très important
de s'imposer donc de s'imposer comment
c'est important d'abord de le nier son
identité sont le fait de s'affirmer en
tant que femme de s'affirmer en tant que
noir de poche avoir à choisir les luttes
donc ne pas avoir à choisir aujourd'hui
je plus fameux suis plus noir mais
vainement de dénoncer des deux font
partie de mon identité et ce parfois ça
peut être difficile à saisir pour
certaines personnes je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de pression en fait parce que
d'un côté on veut plaire on veut
s'adapter à la société d'acquêts on veut
travailler comme les collègues mais il
ya aussi une pression de notre
communauté qui qui nous voit en fait
comme un espoir qui nous porte vers
l'avant qui nous dit souvent nous
représenter les gens leur faire entendre
notre notre voix
c'est un défi j'ai pas encore trouvé de
solution puisque les études alors je
suis une jeune pousse donc je commence
j'aime jouer les jeunes pousses aux
dents longues mais c'est un défi de tous
les instants en fait de cesser de marier
ses multiples identités pour évoluer et
d'avoir les mêmes opportunités que le
reste de mes collègues qui l'a dit tout
à l'heure à l'est son embauche souvent
des gens qui nous ressemblent
c'est aussi le réflexe naturel humain et
si à force d'avoir plus de gens comme
vous qu'on va retrouver plus de
diversité au sein des équipes qu'on va
réussir à s'imposer
je suis très content quand il n'existe
plus une bureau de la diversité il ya
plus de diversité en fait on est comme
ça on est on est on est différents puis
la richesse c'est la scène est très très
spécial canton on n'a pas besoin d'une
quotas on n'a pas besoin d avoir noah en
chinois une façon de l'amérique latine
pour que notre entreprise soit vu comme
on est on est diverse et ça c'est très
spécial c'est 2036 ce concept de
diversité va mourir de sa proprement je
le prédis pourquoi parce que d'après les
projections en 2036 les minorités
visibles seront à peu près 40% vont
représenter comment % savez la
population il serait plus utile de
parler de diversité gars ce que je vous
souhaite dans ce métier si c'était moi
j'ai 15 ans je travaille et je travaille
quatre ans en allemagne un moment donné
que je venu au canada il ya un collègue
qui me demande qui va prendre la place
de kiel
ouais l'éternelle question et je lui
répondu tout simplement la mienne et je
vous la souhaite pour toujours votre
place elle est belle et bien ici à votre
place et ça fait plaisir de l'entendre
on a vu le collègue était un profond
amis sénégalais d'origine qui est décédé
aujourd'hui c'est nous dit on faisait ce
mythe sissi sein cancer
quand il vous prend il vous garde
vanessa destiné à l'iss chantal chant
dames les originaux merci beaucoup à vie
trois d'être passé baboo discuter de
sujets ici à tam tam ce fut un plaisir
et on adore parler longtemps
[Musique]